welcome to this video playing panopticon
with black here the Kings Indian I
wonder oh this guy is really going on
going at me with the the four pawns
attack I think Bishop g4 was how I
display diem
there was something with e 5 I really
have forgotten the exact move order
cakes and 97 or something I say I no no
I had this was the wrong move autumn man
I needed to play 97 first this is not
good really not now the bishop 1g4 is
not making much sense okay
and try to take on d5 with the sea pawn
them play 96 to set up a blockade
problem is that the night on 86 is not
really well placed him at some it's not
a very comfortable position and I can
also play that all the time okay I don't
know what this is a good decision it's
not so much the bishop pair but it's oh
yeah sometimes the bishop on g7 has a
useful role in keeping them some
important square cm protected okay it's
it's very weakling but if I don't do
that I don't really see what what type
of counter play I'll ever get always
taking okay maybe I get some some peace
play
the night on a six still an issue I
would like to somehow exchange it for
the bishop on d3 on anything but if I go
to see 7s immediately always Bishop c5
as well with them with problems yeah he
definitely will not take the night I
don't think so
what do I do with this knowledge I mean
maybe yeah to be formed maybe start with
this maybe I can play really not be for
2d three at some point if he takes then
i get if i NC 4 for the night oh wow
it's not really going for some subtle
maneuvers right probably just a good
move it's probably just a good news
nothing I love to play but maybe takes
rook takes it takes on f 59 f five at
least this looks like some activity I'm
not so sure the structure looks looks
bad prob like somehow but maybe I get
some activity I wonder fer I wonder if
he should simply keep the Queen's on and
he did maybe he's really threatening to
take on F Phi of them I play age 6
another really active of age 6 nano bad
idea Queen g6 maybe I don't know what
the position i really like
at least I'm not hopelessly behind on
the clock not sure about this one this
looks active the night on f5 sir is
something now is grabbing them that's
greedy right see 522 D three maybe
okay let's let's see taking it
definitely will give me give me decent
play maybe maybe it's not very ambitious
but where is it going ham I'm going on
going right into the middle of the board
trying to use them use them long
diagonal
take here okay where this deep own is
really is really some some some cause
for concern but okay can probably stop
it with 95
if I take his gut okay 96 if I get the
bishop to d4 here B 6 p-6 for Bishop
deform this this will activate me if I
can take you for now I just gave away a
forbes not a good at jack ok this is
active but not really sufficient I guess
time warning d6 rookie to problem stop
the porn
mmm not good check maybe I've control
que no I've God rakesh mean you just
blundered that
white resins chair not a really deserved
victory or anything it's always always
somewhere in trouble I thought here
should be reasonably active but I don't
know took here Jim this was source code
Jam I was just trying to stay active
poor for the porn but of course black
should never ever win this here went
went to the cell 46 maybe I d6 seems to
be a problem also liked by the computer
95 this is very very dangerous m4 for
example yeah but why white is better in
any case okay look a to immediately
seems to be good for p6 was a clever
move but with was mostly overlooking
that if I hangs here black seems to be
okay here I'm not to check yeah I hear
what I think probably should maybe
should win with but I'm active on the
second i'm not i'm not sure if white
really wins maybe he should yeah well
losing is this is quite check out of the
picture but he be just blundered this
with no time on the clock that's the
same problem with them what I'm always
yeah complaining about that you don't
have any increment you will see that you
have 20 seconds less here he in this
case it's him and you start to panic try
to play very quickly know that you
probably lose on
and then you even make make those kind
of silly mistakes here giving up the
game where he was always better okay
thanks for watching